hi there honey Bernie what do you do I
work in high charter bank k-chart
we do not judge you it's an honest
profession off you go with your story
okay so basically I was on a boat on the
way to pipi island in Thailand a couple
years ago with my mate that she offered
me a seasickness table and I said nah
she'd be right made this would be fine
turns out it was one of the roughest
seas that I've ever experienced in my
life
it was so up and down within 30 minutes
half the boat started throwing up it was
disgusting I started growing green and
of course I grabbed a sick bag strap in
it sorry um and basically it was about
to throw it out because it's disposable
outside the side of the boat until I
realized that like a massive wave it hit
the boat and it went flying up had
smashed it into this poor old lady who
any English and went all over her face
and her chasing her down the next hour
if you're watching right now I'm still
sorry I thought question was it a lumpy
one or was a water also like Rita like
watery vomits fine
oh I got the borderline one for flip
walk flip
all right and I started to talk to her
and she's like um she's like no you you
you speak that way first and I'll speak
this way and I come back to you about
this and they said that they have
reduced your part in the film to a
non-speaking role animation